Last time we, uh, found out how
to, how to evaluate options,
especially stopping options where you
don't, you don't have so many options,
either do something you don't do it.
This is the simplest kind of option.
And we discovered through
two examples at least that,
uh, the option is worth
more than people realize.
So this time we're going to apply that
and that the way to figure out exactly
what it's worth and exactly what to do
is to, is to work by backward induction.
So we're,
we're going this time,
we're going to apply that reasoning to
the two most important options that a in
the economy.
One is callable bonds,
and then a much more important
one is the mortgage option.
And you know,
all of you at some time in your lives
will probably own houses and have a
mortgage option and have to think about
what kind of mortgage to get and what
the option is. So I want to teach
you how to think about that problem.
So let's start with the
callable bond problem.
Oh, got to turn this on. Oh,
so let's start here with the
column will bond. Problem.
So callable bonds are issued
by corporations and they pay,
usually an interest rates say 9%.
So the bond pays 9%,
9%,
and then some years later it pays 109.
Okay.
But at, at any point in
time, you have the option,
the company has the option of
calling the bond and calling it for,
so it's going to pay nine plus a
hundred at the end. So here it's nine.
So at any time the company has
the option of calling the bond.
So what does that mean? It means after
it's paid the nine. So the bond, the,
the, the companies issued a bond
promising to pay nine for say, 10 years,
and then the principal and the 10th
year, this is year 10, the tall,
the total of 109. Okay. So that's
the simplest possible bond.
And the company
occasionally has the option.
We'll see in a minute why would want this
option has the option of saying, okay,
we don't want to make the
rest of those payments.
We want to get out of our promise.
We've just paid you nine,
we'll pay off the extra
hundred. Uh, you know,
that we're eventually going to have
to, oh, and we'll call it a day.
So this is the payment.
Okay.
And this is the remaining balance.
So for a a callable bond,
there's really it,
the remaining balance is always a hundred.
So it's pretty obvious that if you've
made an arrangement, so, and you know,
I owe you like for example,
the prototype called mortgage,
where was there exactly?
This kind, somebody borrows
money from you and they say,
I promise to pay you $9 a year until the
last year when I'm gonna pay you 109.
This is called for those old mortgages,
it was called the balloon payment. Okay.
But, uh, in, in chemical bonds, it's
just the principle payment, you know,
the hundred face value of the bond.
So the person who borrowed the money
in as agreed to pay off over the years,
he might have a reason why the house he
put up as collateral is no longer going
to be his house.
He might want to move,
in which case the lender doesn't have
a house anymore backing the loan.
And they have to, some have some way of
resolving the loan in ending it. Okay.
And so the question is,
after you've made a payment,
how can you resolve the rest of the loan,
which was supposed to go
on for six more years.
Will you just agree to pay a hundred
and then you call it quit. Okay.
So that's us. That's a, that's a
typical kind of bond. All right?
So a non callable bond is you've committed
to paying the $9 in the 109 at the
end and you have no option
to get out of a thing.
So we want to study what the differences
in value between the non callable bond,
where you're obliged to pay
the whole thing until the end.
And the callable bond where you can
get out of it by paying a hundred.
And it's easy to see why a callable
bond might've been, uh, invented,
especially for a mortgage when you've got
this balloon payment because you know,
you might want to dissolve the debt,
but by,
by putting this option
to dissolve the debt,
you drastically change
the value of the promise.
And that's what we want to calculate,
how much that changes.
So why might it change? Well,
the interest rates might change.
They might go up or down soon.
We're going to have them going up
or down in a more complicated way.
But suppose that the interest rate starts
somewhere like it's seven, you know,
8% maybe and it uh,
it could go up to some number.
Now I'm always going to do
a geometric random walk.
This has become very fashionable in
finance and you should be asking the
question, you know, does it is a special
that we're only have two possibilities?
I'm the world life has many
more than two possibilities.
Suppose we had hundreds of possibilities.
Would that make a difference?
The answers is not going
to make a difference,
but we're going to have to see why.
So in the geometric random walk,
literally the thing can go
up or down, um, each period.
So what does it go to if this is our zero,
the next period we say it goes to
our zero times e to the volatility,
which I usually call sigma.
Okay.
Plus maybe a drift plus d and here it's
going to go to r zero e let's write it a
little more room
are zero e to the sigma,
e to the minus sigma,
plus
minus plus d. Okay, so
what's happened here?
The interest rates started at 8% it gets
multiplied by e to the d which is just
a number. Okay, so it's maybe
tending to go up over time.
If DNS positive or if dia zero think of
d zero are zero on average it's going to
stay at our zero but there's
some uncertainty. Maybe
the interest rate goes up.
We multiply it by some number eight of
the sigma and then we multiplied by the
reciprocal of the same number,
we divide it by eight of the sigma.
So using the exponential notation just
makes the computations and the computer
easier because the
computer's adding numbers.
You know this thing over here is going
to be our zero e to the two sigma Plus d
plus to be right and
this will be our zero e.
This will just be our zero e to the two
D and this will be our zero e to the
minus two sigma plus two.
So the computer in calculating the
interest rate at every step is adding
exponents and it makes the calculation
when you're doing gazillions of nodes
much faster.
So that's why we use this.
It's a traditional to use this notation,
but really all I'm saying is you multiply
or divide by the same number to see
what the next interest rate is.
And on top of that you might be sort of
increasing all the things over time just
because you think the interest
rates are going over time.
So that's how we're modeling uncertainty
and everybody's supposed to understand
what the probabilities are of these moves.
Okay.
So for now that's going to be our model
of uncertainty and in a few minutes I'm
going to try and indicate why complicating
it won't have much effect. Okay.
So there are any questions. This
notation I hope isn't too complicated.
Are there any questions about
the interest rate process?
I'm assuming the uncertainty
that people are facing. Yeah,
why is that?
Okay.
Cause I'm assuming that if there weren't
uncertainty the interest rate was going
to keep steadily rising by multiplying
by the constant e to the B.
So here I have multiplied it by eight
of the d here on multiplying it again by
either the B I'm going to
multiply it again by eating the d.
So d is a 10th of a percent.
It means that the interest rate is rising
at a 10th of a percent every period.
And you know you might just think interest
rates are going to get higher in the
future.
You might have a more complicated
function than steadily rising are steadily
falling.
It's just that this is the simplest t
to add a little complication without
making it too complicated,
steadily rising are steadily falling and
binomial uncertainty with the easiest
simple things I could do.
Of course a more realistic thing.
We do more complicated things.
Any other questions about what this means?
I know this can be confusing,
this notation,
so let's just figure out the notation.
Make sure you understand it before I
move on cause it's really nothing but
notation. I'm just saying the
interest rate is, you know, 8% today.
It can go up a little or down
little, uh, and then you know,
after that it can go up or down and the
percentage rise and fall is always going
to be the same relative to adrift
and the Drift might be zero.
The drift might be positive.
Okay, so to take it again,
example,
let's take an example here.
Okay, so this is a plug, everything in?
Yes. This is a spreadsheet that
you have called callable bond.
I did a little work on it,
but not much.
It's basically your spreadsheet.
Everything's plugged in here.
Sing that. Right. Okay. So
what I've done is I've said,
let's take over here the year.
So here are the years, you know,
zero one, two, three blah
blah, up to 31 or something.
Then the bond coupon rate is 9% so the
bond is going to pay $9 9% of the face is
always 100 we'll pay $9 till the end.
So if you look at,
if I take the bond
maturity of 30 down here,
I've got the $9 payments and
I've got the remaining principal,
the remaining balance,
what you can pay to dissolve the contract.
You could after the first year,
after paying nine immediately afterwards
you could pay a hundred and say forget
about the whole thing. Okay?
So that's, that's that.
And so it goes all the way
to year 30 and searing youth,
your 30th see you're paying 109 and then
then the bond is over 109 and by then
the bond is over. There's
nothing to talk about. Okay?
So now I start off the interest rates.
Some are at 8% okay?
And I take the volatility,
it's always said in hundreds.
I think the volatility is 16 that means
sigma equals 16 over a hundred cause
that's the way people talk
about volatility of 16% so
that is a sort of standard
volatility.
12 or 16% is about the annual volatility
of these things traditionally.
So I've taken the volatility at 16% so
I take the drift to zero to make that
simple. The DS disappearing.
Okay? So what does that mean?
It means that whatever the thing was
last period when it moves to here,
I take the old number. Okay? At
the top there, if you read this,
I'm taking,
this is the up multiplier.
I just take of the signal plus d
and that's what this says over here.
Exponent of, you know, just as that, okay,
so that's the Apollo supplier and that's
the download multipliers. So then, okay,
and so let's just see how that looks.
So if I look at the interest rates,
I started 8%
and they can go up,
you know, by that
multiplier, 16% up, 16% down.
And see if we take 8% you add 16% too.
It's slightly more than 16% because
either the 0.16 is a little bit more than
16% you think 16 for eight 16% off
is about 9.3% interest and 16% down,
you go from 8% to 6.8% and
things just go up or down.
So that's the uncertainty. Okay?
So that's the, that's the, uh,
that's what interest
rates are going to do.
So everybody knows that you started at
8% and interest rates can go up or down
by 16% for the next 30 years.
The question is what's the value of the
bond? Well, if you couldn't call it,
okay, you're, please interrupt
me if you're not following.
If he couldn't call it non callable bond,
the,
the why would you expect it to
have such a high price? Well,
because the interest rate, you know,
is, sorry, the interest rate remember,
is only 8% and on average it's going
to stay at 8% it could go up or down,
but you know, it's always
coming back. The middle,
the middle thing there is always
8% so if you look in the middle,
it's 8% 8% 8% 8% so sort of the geometric
average is 8% on average it's going to
be 8% that's less than the payment nine.
So the poor bondholder is overpaying
paying nine every year when the interest
rates only 8% and on average is
going to be 8% so obviously the, the,
the bond issuer is giving a very good
deal to the buyer by paying nine when the
interest rates only 8% and you know
how you calculate this at every step,
you'd have to do it by backward
induction. So you'd write down, uh,
and we've done this before,
the value at every node.
V S okay.
So if I take a note here,
what's the value of it? The value
of it. So, so what's the value?
So I could do a con, okay. I don't know
if I need to do a concrete example. If I,
how do I do this by backward induction?
So I keep going like that,
right? And then the, the
life is going to end.
This is the last payment somewhere.
Let's say the last payment is here.
So you're going to get a hundred 909
no matter what because that's where the
life,
that's the last period.
100900900 nine 109 okay,
so we know what the value is here.
Uh,
at the end is zero beyond this point.
So the question is,
and we know what the value is here,
you just take the inch,
you know going to pay 109 no matter what.
So you just take the interest
rate back here. Okay?
So we know what the value is here.
So the question is if you figured
out the value at the end of the tree,
which is trivial because the
last page at the very end,
you're just going to get 109 for sure.
Can you figure out what the value
is at the beginning of the tree?
And the way you do that is for
every node you say to yourself,
it doesn't matter which node you are,
like this one or that one,
let's call it note s.
Okay?
So the value of note s this is the value
just after paying the coupon.
Okay? So you've paid the coupon, you
paid the nine. Now what's the value?
Well the non call price.
So what's do non call
non call bond.
What is the value going to be?
Well just after paying the nine here,
what's the value of what's left?
Well half the time, so you're going
to have to go up here. So half that.
So first of all you're going to
discount by the interest rate here.
So it's one over one plus r s so you're
discounting by the interest rate there.
Then half the time you're
going to have to, um,
you'll go up. Okay. And so what
we have to do, if you go up,
you'll have to pay nine because that's
the required payment and then you'll be
left in the same situation except that
you'll be at the upstage or whatever the
value is there plus the s up.
If this note is asked, this node, we call
s up and this snowed, we call s down.
So if you knew,
so I'm doing this by backward induction.
Remember I'm saying suppose towards the
end of the tree I figured out what is
the value of the bond just after
making the coupon payments,
since there are no coupon payments at
the end. I know the value of zero. Okay,
so having done it at the end and working
my way backwards now by induction,
I can figure out the value
at any previous notes.
So suppose I'm here and I've already
figured out the value of all future nodes.
The value here is simply going to be value
here is just after the coupon payment
is going to be, I'm going to
discount it, the interest rate here,
one plus r s half the time I'm going
to have to go up here with Jason,
I'm going to pay nine and
then what am I going to do?
I'm going to be at a situation and I've
just made the coupon payment and I've
see what the value left is. Well that's
the number you already calculated.
So vs up plus one half.
If I go down,
I'm down to here,
it's nine again plus vsts.
So I mean that's pretty simple.
Okay.
And now I just have to solve
it by backward induction.
So that's what I did in this tree. Here's
the interest rates. And now back here,
here's the present value of a non
callable bonds. So at any node,
let's pick one like this one.
What's the value?
It says it's one over one plus the
interest rate times the probability p 0.5
that's a half times the payment.
That's $9 plus what the
value would be if I went up.
Cause Jay one 49 is, is
this, no, that's Jay.
That's Jay one 49 here.
So it's just exactly what I wrote.
Half 50% probability j
four is the $9 at the top,
plus the probability,
the plus the value of what I would get
here plus a half times the same $9 if I,
I'd have to pay if I went down plus
the value that I'd get down here.
So that's an extremely simple
calculation to do. And because Xcel,
you know, is a brilliant,
as I say, I'm created by uh,
Kapore the whose sister was my classmate
and it was two years ahead of me at
Yale. You know, Excel immediately
understands, he called the Lotus,
immediately understands that a,
if you give all these directions,
he can't figure out the value here unless
you know what the value was forward.
So Xcel understands that you should keep
going forward and starting at the end
and at the end it knows what the
value is because it's to zero.
So having got the value zero at the end,
it then works backwards all the way
through the tree and gets the value at the
beginning. He gets it 113 so
it's exactly what we want to do.
And he's just written this brilliant
program that understands, you know,
if there's a dependency,
you can't calculate this
without knowing this. He says,
okay,
I don't know this.
I'll go forward in the program
to hear I can't do these either.
I'll go all the way to the end.
Now everything's zero.
So I know all these
numbers now step by step,
I can go backwards and get all of them.
That's what Xcel is doing and
it does it instantly. Okay?
So there's no doubt about that, right?
You all are way ahead of me on that. Okay,
so the is 113 that's a huge number.
So obviously it's a very generous company.
The company may not want to be so
generous. So the company says, look,
we want maybe to,
uh,
we want to be able to call the
bond at a hundred. Okay. And, uh,
now with the w, so that's simple
option. What's it going to be?
What's the value going to be?
Well,
obviously the company could call her
right away at a hundred so it's going to
make the value go all the way down to 100
because the company now has the option
whenever it wants to, like at the very
beginning before making the first payment,
it could pay a hundred here.
Okay.
Or it could pay the $9 and then pay
a hundred here. So the question is,
should the company do it and when do
you think the company will exercise the
option?
Okay.
Why would the company, why wouldn't the
company exercise the option right away?
So here it is,
the bonds worth 113 every period
the is promising to pay $9.
That's like a 9% interest.
The interest rates in the economy,
only 8% at the beginning here.
So it's losing money right from the start.
Why shouldn't the company just say, okay,
you know, we gave ourselves the option.
We're taking it right away.
We're going to just pay you a hundred
and cancel the whole thing at the
beginning. Why wouldn't
they do that? Okay,
well hang on for one second. Someone
else, why wouldn't they do that?
See, the puzzle is the company can
pay his promise to pay $9 forever.
That's like 9% on the
hundred dollar coupon.
The interest rate is only 8% now,
so the company's paying more money,
$9 then you know it could have borrowed
and only had to pay $8 so the guy buying
it is getting this who'd huge bonus.
He's getting $9 coupons
instead of $8 coupons.
He's probably telling his friends, you
know, who aren't marking to market.
Look at my return.
I've got $9 as until the first year.
Look at that great 9% return I got
in my investment of 100 why is uh,
why won't the company call
it right at the beginning?
What's the company waiting for?
Yup.
Back Up.
Exactly.
Because if the interest rates go way up,
then the company, maybe the
interest rates, you know,
not after a very short amount of time,
if the company gets lucky,
the interest rates are gonna go up. So
here, here are the interest rates, right?
So after a very short amount of time,
you know, two years you get the up thing,
the interest rates are 11% so all of
a sudden the company's looking great.
It's borrowed at 9% and it's
a only having to, you know,
and the interest rates are
actually 11% so that, so,
um, you know, every time you know,
effectively it's borrowing from the,
from the guy 9% and it's able to invest
the money at 11% to put it another way,
the present value of the payments left
from then are much less than a hundred so
it's glad it made the deal.
And on the other hand,
if the interest rate goes down far enough,
okay,
then the company will be able to call
the thing present value of the payments.
If it couldn't call,
would be way higher,
but because it can call it can never
do suffer worse than having to pay a
hundred.
Okay.
So you see that it's the interest rates
are going up or down and he couldn't
call it. Okay. Then it's a,
and you couldn't call it.
Okay. Then when interest rates go up,
that's really good news for the company.
Okay. Because now the interest rates
are over 9% on average going forward.
So actually the Wa the present
value of payments is 98.
That's less than a hundred. On the
other hand, if interest rates go down,
then the company's really screwed. Now
the present value of what it owes is 127.
Okay.
And at the beginning it's 113.
So as interest rates go
further and further down,
the company's made a worse
and worse bond issue.
But it doesn't suffer
very much because of that,
because it can always get out of
it's deal by calling it. Okay.
So in fact, astonishingly, um,
it doesn't even call the first
time. So here, here's the OP,
here's the value and the,
when the company behaves optimally,
it won't call the first time when
interest rates go up, it says a high,
we're going to make money. That's
great. But when interest rates go down,
we just saw that that's, that's, you know,
now the interest rates 6%
and it's still paying nine.
The company's still not
going to call the bond.
It won't call the bond till the interest
rates go down all the way to 5%. Okay.
So anyway,
by backward induction,
you get the value of the
callable bond is 95 which is um,
95.5 to nine, which is a lot. Uh,
so let's, let's do, let's write those
down. In fact, Sovi callable bond
95.5 to nine.
Okay.
A non call.
Was 113 point something
which I forgot already.
MMM.
Okay.
So I hope you're falling cause it's going
to get a lot more surprising when we
do mortgages,
but it's the same logic.
One 13.2361 13.236.
Okay, so the call option
is worth 18% of the bond.
It's a huge thing. It sounds so simple.
Of course you should get out of the,
a lot of the,
you should dissolve the thing for a value
of a hundred that's the only natural
thing to do.
So it's perfectly reasonable you would
think for the company to give itself that
option. Look guys, we're borrowing
money, but there may be some reason why,
you know, things get too
complicated. We can, you know,
our company might close down.
We want to keep our promise,
so he just want to pay off the loan
at a hundred so give us that option.
Even if our company
doesn't close down well,
the company has just taken an
incredibly valuable option.
Instead of making a promise worth 113
it's made a promise worth 95 okay.
Now before I move,
so any questions about that?
You could all get that and you all see
why that's happening and it's a bigger
number than you'd expect.
Yup.
Okay.
When should they call it?
Okay. They should call it.
You can tell when they should call it
because you'll know when they call it.
Because if they do call it,
what's the value?
Okay, so I, I didn't, I
didn't work out the, the, the,
what's the backward induction?
Oh, sorry. So let's write down
the formula when you do call it,
how could I have forgotten to do that?
So what do you do?
What when you do call it,
so value,
how do you figure this out? I just skip
this. Sorry. Value of callable bond.
Yeah.
Okay.
So vs what is that going to equal?
Now you've got an option.
Okay.
Just after making the vs this is,
remember this is a value just after
coupon payment.
Okay. So what is the value?
Just after the coupon payment,
that's when you have to call in a second.
You'll see why that's the
way the rule works. Okay.
So the just after the coupon payment,
what's the value of the bond? Well,
now that you have the option,
you can pay the minimum
of the remaining balance.
Okay.
Okay. So if it's a time,
it's a hundred all the time.
This is just going to be a hundred you
could pay a hundred or you could keep
going.
So if you keep going,
it's going to be one plus r s
times the same thing a half.
And then you're going to have to make
the coupon payment the next, you know,
up you'll go. You know you're,
you're, you're going to,
so just a
second. Where should we go? So here, this
is the interest rate. So at any node,
you know, you can pick any one like
here in the tree, this one, okay,
that's the interest rate. So at that
node, you could, if you wanted to,
after making the coupon payment there,
you could pay the hundred and say, okay,
we've made the payment,
I'm making a hundred more,
let's just call the whole thing quits.
But if you don't,
then something you're going to move on.
And when you're going to move on,
you're going to go either up to here.
Okay?
So that's what the probability a half,
you have to make the coupon payment.
And then again,
you'll have the option of a,
you know, paying your way out of it.
Dissolving the contract or continuing.
So you just have VSU because
that's exactly the value.
Just after making the coupon
payment at node Su. Okay,
that's VSU and so it's going to take
into account that you're minimizing
something. So you see vs the value
in any node takes into account.
You could minimize by possibly paying the
balance and dissolving it or you could
continue.
And so if you continue and things go up,
you have to make the coupon and
then you're going to face a choice.
But we assume by backward induction you've
already figured out the value of that
thing.
Maybe it's paying the hundred,
maybe it's not paying the hundred whatever
that is plus a half times nine plus
VSD.
Okay.
So the only difference
between this callable,
non call case and the call case is you
notice that the second term is exactly
the same in the two cases.
But here we've added the minimum of a
hundred in that cause you either can
continue or you could pay a hundred.
Of course the values vsq appear and vas
are not the same as the VSS here because
they've all been concatenated by
taking the minimum with a hundred. So,
um, okay. So how can you,
so the computer now is going to solve
this by backward induction and now how can
you tell what the
computer's decided to do?
Well you look at if the computer
said it's a good time to call,
that means it's going to,
the value at that point is going to be a
hundred cause it's called by paying the
remaining balance, which is a
hundred. So if you go now to the, um,
if you go to the present
value of non call,
you get all these present values you
known as the interest rate goes down,
you get crushed. Okay. Of course,
because you have the same
payments and lower interest rates,
you're discounting buy less. But the
callable bond, so you shouldn't call here,
it's 99.9 so that means when the guy in
the computer took the minimum a hundred
and this thing, it took
this, which was 99,
it didn't use the option to call at a
hundred but if things go down again,
then it's going to call it a hundred
okay?
So it's got a threshold here where the
interest rate has to go pretty far before
it calls at a hundred okay?
It has to go down twice.
But you notice this
threshold as time goes on,
the threshold is going to get a tighter.
So even if you're at the same interest
rate for years, you know, this is a one,
two, three, four, this is
five years later, okay?
When the interest rate's gone down
once below the minimum bar here,
five years later, you will call when
the interest rate is, you know, uh,
instead of 8% to 6.8% but one year
later he won't call if it's 6.8%.
And why is that? Because at
this, no, well why is that?
How come if in the first year
the interest rate went from,
remember it started at 8% and it goes
down to 6.8% here you don't call on the
other hand, if things had gone, you know,
stayed the same for a few years and then
in year five or year or whatever this
year us, how many years have
we got here? One, two, three.
No year zero one, two, three,
four. So if a year for the,
um, the interest rate
goes down to a year five,
the interest rate goes down
to 6.8%. Okay. And you're one,
if the interest rate went down
from 8% to 6.8%, you wouldn't call.
But if the interest rates sort of bounces
around and in the near five is backed
down at 6.8% you will call,
why would you call here?
Even though in the exactly the same
situation, you didn't call here,
why call here and not here.
You can tell what you call cause those
are a hundreds and the computer's pick
the minimum equal to 100 so why is it
that it's going to call here but not here
even though the interest rates are
exactly the same, 6.8% in both cases.
Yes.
Yeah,
exactly. So the point is the only
reason not to call here, you're getting,
you're paying through the nose,
it's horrible.
The interest rate 6% you're paying
nine, it's terrible. But you're hoping,
you know maybe things
are going to turn around,
the interest rate's going to soar,
then it's going to be a great deal for me.
So I'm willing to have some short run
losses in case I get a gigantic gain on
the upside.
And I know that I'm protected on the
downside because of things go down again,
I can cut my losses and
just call it a hundred okay.
But if you run out of time and things
are still here, the interest rate,
6.8 is still way below a 9% which is the
coupon you're paying and you don't have
much time for the interest
rates to go back up.
You better call ven and cut
your losses. Exactly. So, okay,
so that's the whole logic of the thing.
So any questions about that? And it's a,
as I said,
the options worth much more than it seems.
Okay.
Could you all do a problem like this?
You'll find out.
Okay.
All right. So now let me just do
one more example. Suppose, okay,
so now I want to say I
want to do an aside here.
Suppose that we had a trinomial
tree instead of a binomial tree.
Okay. So I have the same picture, but
instead of three to two things happening,
I say three things could happen
or five things could happen. Okay.
Now how would I create? So
I would, I would take the
same tree and put this here,
you know, and I, I'd always allow for
something happening in the middle. Okay.
And then of course it gets
more complicated and I'm
gonna be able to draw it
because now this thing, three things
could happen from here and from here,
three things could happen from
here. You know, I have three things.
So I have a trinomial tree like that,
right?
We're always three things could happen.
So from here I could go here,
stay the same, or go up. Okay.
Now, if I had a trinomial tree,
and of course you could think of an end,
no meal tree,
would I keep the same numbers here?
Well,
I can't keep the same numbers
because if I have a half and a half,
that doesn't allow any probability
for going in the middle.
So I'll put a quarter here and a quarter.
Okay, now what do I have to do to
these numbers? Well, the drift,
I'm going to leave the same because on
average it's still going to go up by D.
Okay? So this was, remember
ours, your e to the minus sigma,
plus D. Okay. Do I want
to, but the s you know,
so this is a probability a half. Okay.
I just made up three numbers a quarter,
quarter and a half, or the
trinomial tree. Suppose those,
suppose those are my numbers.
If I want to make this tree
comparable to the binomial tree,
what does it mean to be comparable?
It means that the standard deviation
and the expectation of the interest rate
ought to be the same. Okay. So, um,
so I'm using the fact that if they're
normally distributed random variables,
all I need to know.
So if there were mill,
if there were millions of successor
interest rates and I took them with this,
uh, then there are millions of
these successor interest rates,
then as long as the standard deviation
and the expectation were the same,
no matter how I put the probabilities,
I'd get almost the same variable because
it would be normally distributed with
that standard deviation and that
expectation and normally distributed. Um,
as I said means it's determined by
standard deviation and expectation.
So, um, what, what do I,
okay, so I've just picked a
quarter, a half and a quarter.
It's as if I had two moves where you can
get to ups to go to here an up or down
or a down or up to go here
and two downs to go here.
That's why I picked a quarter, a half
and a quarter. It's like I added two,
six month moves here. Uh, and
called it a one year move.
Okay. So if I keep dividing the process
and having it happen quicker and quicker,
I'm going to, you know, by the,
by the central limit theorem going to
get something normally distributed with a
corresponding standard deviation and mean.
So what is going to end up as the
standard deviation here and here? Okay,
well I I know to get the same variance
before I had a half sigma squared plus a
half sigma squared that equals
sigma squared. But now my,
my variance is going to be
a quarter sigma. You know,
this is the new sigma hat squared
plus a quarter sigma hat squared.
Cause I'll go down whatever the sigma.
So now I should put a sigma hat here.
So of quarter sigma hat squared.
So if I look at the variance of the,
of the exponent,
it's going to be a quarter sigma hat
squared plus a quarter sigma hat squared
plus a half times zero because half the
time you just get the average. Okay?
So therefore it's,
it means a half sigma hat
squared has to equal six,
it has to equal sigma squared.
So therefore sigma hat squared has equal
to sigma squared and therefore sigma
hat has equal the square
root of two times sigma.
So I should put the square root of two
here and the a square root of two here.
Okay, so now if I do a
trinomial, but I have, um,
you know, for the Trinomial
to be similar to the binomial,
the binomial would be sort of here and
here and the trinomial in knows a lot of
probability you're stuck in the middle.
So to get the same kind of average spread,
I'm going to have to have this thing
sticking further out and this thing
sticking further out.
But if I choose my numbers by multiplying
by the square root of two here, okay,
in the square root of two here,
the standard deviation of this trinomial
is the same as the standard deviation
of the binomial. And the
expectation of the two are the same.
So a truck and I could do
the same thing with an end,
no meal or an any number
thing I wanted to,
and I could always pick the standard
deviation properly, uh, you know,
pick these nodes properly so that I
had the same standard deviation and
expectation as I did with
the original binomial tree.
So just because I've got three
nodes or five nodes on average,
they can turn out to be the
same and the average spread,
the average spread squared can
also be the same as the binomial.
And if I do that,
okay,
I'm going to get a shockingly
similar answer. So,
um,
so let's just see what we get.
So what do I have to do now? I have to
do, I have to go to trinomial? Okay.
So what did we do here?
We did 9% was the coupon we paint.
And the interest rates start at
8% in the volatility was a 16.
So if I go to Trinomial, okay, um,
okay, I put 9% to start 30 years, uh, 8%.
The starting rate and volatility is 16,
and now I have to do the up multiplier.
Okay. And by doing that, you see I've
multiplied up there in that formula,
there's a square root of two there,
two square root of two.
So I've got just a slightly
more complicated thing. Uh,
I've just multiplied by the square root
of two and that's what I've got all my
notes. So otherwise it's the same
thing. I do the same backward induction,
except instead of being a half a half,
you know,
I put a quarter here and a quarter here.
So it will be a quarter VSU
plus a quarter VSD plus a half,
you stay the same,
which will be nine plus v s,
um, same, whatever that is. Okay.
And so it's exactly the same. Okay.
So I probably lost you. So
let me just say, I want to,
I want to convince you that this binomial
assumption is not such a special case.
Okay? So you should be thinking to
yourself two things happening next year.
That's ridiculous. I could
imagine a million things
happening next year. So I say,
okay, I believe it a million
things could happen next year.
So I'm going to write down a million
things, not any million things.
I'm going to say. Let's suppose that
instead of two things happening in a year,
I say I divide via what can happen over
the year into a million different up and
down moves. Now in order to replicate
sort of the original binomial,
those million up and down moves,
let's say 250 of them, one every day,
those daily moves of course going to
be much smaller than the one year move.
But if I make the drift be the
old drift divided by two 50,
and the, the, uh, new standard
deviation of the tiny things be,
um, you know, the right ratio of
a standard deviation, then when I,
when I compute, you know, the
standard deviation at this,
of all the nodes here,
I'll get the same standard deviation is
the binomial and the same drift on the
binomial. Okay? So if I ended
up with three nodes here,
I would just be multiplying by
the square root of two. Okay?
And so by having a trinomial thing
with a slightly adjusted, uh, you know,
move up and down slightly,
spreading it and putting some
probability in the middle,
I can have the same variance
and the same expectation.
If I had thousands of nodes here,
I'd also have the same variants
of the same expectation.
And so I did it just for the trinomial.
So let's see what happens to the value.
If we look now at the interest
rates. Okay. It was an uglier thing.
I couldn't do it quite as I was
too lazy to do it as neatly.
So the interest rates started at 8% and
now they can go up to 10 or down to 6.3
you know, so there are, and then the next
period they can go up to 12 and a half.
So that you see the different moves here.
Remember the other one was 6.8 and nine.
So there,
if you don't get the same
interest rate right away,
you move more violently up or down.
So these three things,
these two are spread out further
than this, but at the same day. Okay.
So what happens to the,
what happens to the price?
The present value of the
non bond is 113.23 and what
was it before 113.236 okay.
It's not so different.
And if I look now at the
value of a callable bond,
it's 95.142 and what was it
before 95.5 to nine okay.
A little bit different.
So you can see that the trinomial thing,
it gives you almost the same
answer as the binomial. And um,
okay. And so if I made the buying
or if I could, all right, so anyway,
I don't want to say
anything more than that.
So no matter how many
nodes you have in the tree,
the binomials going to
give a good approximation,
provided that we shrink the periods
instead of looking at a year,
are looking at daily moves
or minute by minute moves.
As long as those are binomial over a year,
a million things can happen.
And so you can restrict yourself to
binomial without any loss of generality.
Just taking the time period short enough
because if it's a daily binomial over a
year, there's 250 outcomes or something.
And uh, you know, if it's over a minute,
then there are thousands
of outcomes over a year,
even though each move is binomial
and you'll get the same answer. Okay?
So that's that.
All right,
so we've done the a callable bond idea
in the call option is worth a lot.
Now let's talk,
let's take a more concrete example.
The one that you've all heard
your parents talking about.
If you don't know on a house yourself,
which is a mortgage.
And I just want to do the same thing
and help you start to think about how to
value mortgages. Okay?
So what's a mortgage?
A mortgage is you don't have the
balloon payment at the end. You pay
the same amount each period.
So if you have a nine year,
if you have a nine year, if you
have a, let's take a mortgage.
So which example have I done here?
Okay,
so I've got a mortgage rate of 7%
7% coupon, 7% coupon. You can see,
and it's a 30 year fixed rate mortgage,
okay?
Now how much does that mean you
have to pay every year? Why isn't it
nice?
So every year, what are you going to
pay? You're not going to pay seven.
What this means is whatever x you pay
every year, that's your annual payment,
and the 30th year you're
still going to pay X. Okay?
But if I took this all over 1.07 plus
x over 1.07 squared plus this over 1.07
cubed plus this over 1.07 to the 30th I
would get a hundred k equals a hundred
so that's how x is chosen.
So that the constant payment,
the is an annuity of constant x.
Who's present value at the coupon is
equal to 100 that's how you define the
payment on a mortgage.
Okay?
So let's put a mortgage has to be
defined more completely than that.
You also have to say,
what do you get by
dissolving the mortgage?
How much do you have to pay right away?
You have to pay a hundred what would
you have to pay here if you dissolve the
mortgage right after the,
so remaining balance.
Okay.
Equals payment.
Okay?
Just after coupon.
Okay.
Necessary.
Okay?
To dissolve a mortgage.
So what do you think that,
so at the very beginning you,
you're the guy gave you a hundred if you
want to dissolve it and undo what you
should be able to do
it for a hundred okay?
But what about after the very first
year you've paid x? By the way,
x in this case is going to work
out to 8.05 you solve for x,
you get x 0.8 0.05 that 8.05 discounted
at 7% gives you a hundred okay,
so obviously x has to be bigger than
seven because if it were seven everywhere,
you need a 107 at the very end to make
it a hundred of course at the very end,
that's 30 years later. So
that extra hundred can be
compensated by an extra one,
1.05 all the way along,
1.05 all the way along.
It's just the same as an
extra hundred at the end.
So the payment is 8.05 so if
you're paying a 7% mortgage,
your annual payment is going to be
more than 7% it's going to be 8.05
okay. But in fact, yeah. Okay,
so that's the 7% coupon and the
mortgage coupon of mortgage.
Yeah.
Now if you want to get out
of the mortgage, it's called
prepaying. How do you,
what would you have to pay here to get
out of the mortgage, do you suppose?
What's the only logical thing
to have written in the contract?
Okay,
well you could pay a penalty,
but what if you don't want to have a
penalty then what should the guy paid to
get out of the mortgage?
Yeah,
the remaining balance. Yes,
but what is the remaining
balance? That's the question.
What is the remaining balance? Well,
maybe you know what the answer is.
Okay.
Of what's left.
Okay,
so the guy here are the remaining balance
be one ought to be this number without
this. So you've only got 29 payments,
only going to put a one here now.
Right?
So it's B one B squared and being to
the 29th because you've made the first
coupon payment,
you've got 29 years left,
assuming you know the same terms
as before, it still a 7% coupon.
So you should discount the remaining
29 years at 7% to get B one.
Okay, so B. So that's what B one is. Okay.
So as you can see in the
thing B one is 98.94 okay?
Now,
not 98.94 is an interesting number.
You notice that the 8.05
8.05 minus seven okay happens to equal.
Um,
okay.
Okay.
That a plus B one has to equal
a hundred k which is B zero.
Okay.
Okay. So why is that? So you started
owning the guy a hundred okay.
You've borrowed a hundred you all,
I'm a hundred and he's sort
of charging you 7% interest.
That's the way the deal works.
So you would have expected
to only pay $7 next period.
That's to keep up with the 7% interest.
But you know, he doesn't want,
remember why was this more,
why did the old mortgages go
from the balloon payment to this?
Because in the depression in 1933 every
single farmer practically who old the
hundred nine cause there's more
Asians coming up, defaulted.
So the lenders decided they didn't want
to be facing that situation where a guy
owed 109 they'd rather have the guy pay
x every period where there's never this
gigantic payment that he's
going to default. In fact,
by paying x every period that lenders
in a safer and safer situation.
Why is that?
Because he's asking for acts,
which is $8 even though the interest is
$7 so the the homeowners paying 8.05 the
interest was only seven so he's making
an extra payment of $1.05 so what do you
do with the extra $1.05 you write
down the balance. You say, okay,
you've overpaid me by 1.05 I'm no longer,
you're going to say you owe
a hundred you're going to,
oh now a hundred minus
1.05 okay. Uh, you know,
all of this is x 0.05 had a
few decimal places after it.
And so it's going to be a 98.94136 okay,
so that's this gap.
So be zero minus p one
yeah,
the balance went down by exactly what
the overpayment was beyond the interest.
Okay.
So the fact that,
so you're always,
and so the next time the balance is
going to go down even further because the
next time the balance is only be
one the next time what the guy owes.
If he was just paying the interest,
he ought to only 0.07 times B one and
yet he's still going to be paying 8.05 so
B one minus p two so the balance B
two is going to go down even more.
So the gap from 100 to be
one is a very small one.
It's going to be bigger from B one to B
two and keep getting bigger and bigger
because each time the guy's paying eight
oh five but what he owes the balance
that he owes on that,
he's basically borrowed the money
on as a smaller and smaller number.
So he's overpaying the 7% interest by a
bigger and bigger amount and the balance
goes down by more and more each time.
Or to put it another way, if you take,
you know, uh, the first
thing is, you know,
be one is x times 1.07 1.07 squared,
1.07 29 B two is x 1.07 blah blah blah,
x times 1.07 to the 28th.
So the difference between this,
and this is the last payment,
which was one of the 1.07 to the 29th.
The difference between this
and this is the last payment,
which was one of 1.07 to the 30th.
Okay.
And so as that final maturity
gets smaller and smaller,
the gap gets bigger and bigger.
So I'm just rewriting the saying the same
thing in different ways. The roommate.
Okay. So any questions about this?
Did I go too fast or are you with me?
Somebody asks a question if you're lost.
Yes.
Yeah.
Why do I what?
I'm sorry.
Why do I say it louder?
Why do I discount what?
Yes. This. Okay. So let me say
this again. You borrowed a hundred
okay.
The coupon is the agreed upon interest.
So you should all the guy,
$7 or $107 the next period,
right?
Not 100 anymore. There's 7% interest.
Now you all the guy 107 right?
But at that moment when you owed him 107
you paid him eight oh five so the guy
says, look, I lent you a hundred
I expect 107 back. Next period
you pay me eight oh five
that's more, you know, that's,
that's eight oh five so
what's left that you owe me
eight oh five it's,
it's,
it's a a hundred minus the
1.05 so 98.4 something.
Okay, so you see, okay, so
let me just say it again.
You borrowed a hundred the next year
you all 107 we've already taken into
account the interest rate.
That's 107 so we're sitting in next year,
we're no longer sitting back here. B
One is as of next year. So the guy,
you should really buy rights,
be old.
Now the lender should be
owed 107 now because he, he
he lent a hundred last year.
The agreed upon interest is 7% so
he should be getting 107 this year.
What is he getting?
He's getting 8.05 so what's
left is 107 minus 8.05
yeah.
And that's what we have.
What's left is 107 is exactly that.
So what's left is um,
he should be getting,
so this is seven he got paid.
So if I write it this way,
107 he got paid 8.05 so what's,
what's he got?
So a hundred I'm just
rewriting the same thing.
107 minus 8.05 is going to be,
uh,
the new B One k which is
happens to equal 90 you know,
whatever that is.
98.5 4.505 something like that.
98 Oh eight eight 98.95
yeah.
Right.
So this is 1.05.
So 1.05 plus this is a hundred so 107
minus 8.05 is 98.95 you agree with that?
Right.
Okay.
So what I'm saying is a year later you
were owed 107 you were paid 8.05 so
obviously what's left that you're owed
is the difference 98.95 and that's
exactly what the equation was
that I wrote before. Okay.
Any other questions?
Okay, so you can always divide a
mortgage payment into the interest part.
So any mortgage payment x can
be divided into the interest.
Now it's a race this,
and I'm saying it another words.
Okay. So your payments are x everywhere
up to the last period and your remaining
balance is going to be B
one B two B three you know,
and be 30 which is obviously Poopa zero.
Okay.
So you can always get out of the mortgage
by paying after you make a coupon,
payment acts,
you can get out of it by paying be too.
So your mortgage payment is going
to be divided into the interest.
Okay.
And then the scheduled
principal reduction.
Hey,
so here you pay 8.05 you only,
the interest was only 7% so
you've overpaid. So that's
why the balance goes down.
That's the scheduled balance.
It's called principal at scale and
you'll balance reduction. Okay?
And if you want,
you can prepay and pay off
part of the remaining balance.
Any part you want to.
So let me say it again in some period.
Uh, let's say three. What do you, what,
what could you do in period three? Well,
by the time you've
weighed into period three,
you've got to pay the coupon X.
Okay?
Now the coupon x is way in
excess of 7% times been to it's,
it's eight and 7% of a
hundred is less than X.
We're already down to
a balance of being too.
So the ACS is bigger than 7% of B two.
So 7% of B two was the interest.
Okay? But on top of that,
you paid more than that. So that extra
you paid reduced the remaining balance.
That's the scheduled reduction. And the
remaining balance, you paid that off.
You have no choice about that.
But now in addition, if you want,
you can pay the B3 and get
rid of the whole mortgage.
That's the rules of a mortgage.
Is that clear to everybody? Okay,
so any mortgage that you
get works by those rules.
Okay. So we have to figure out
the value of the mortgage somehow.
I feel I'm going too fast cause
someone asks a question if you're lost,
I need to pick out.
Yes.
So what you just said applies to,
as time goes on,
you pay a bigger and bigger
chunk of principal success.
Yes. So the mortgage is
called an amortizing mortgage.
This was a great invention. You
know, at the time of the depression,
after the depression,
I probably had been invented before
but was used in a big way after that.
I don't know the person's
name who invented it and it
has the property that the
roommate first.
It has the property that you're always
paying more because you're paying level
payments. You must always be
paying your principal down.
That makes the lender's safer and safer
because it's the same house protecting
as long as collateral.
We haven't come to collateral and how the
whole world depends on collateral yet,
but we're going to believe me,
we're going to get there. And uh,
so we haven't gotten to collateral yet,
but when we get to it,
the lender's protected by the house,
the amount that's owed to him started a
hundred. It's getting lower every period.
So he's feeling safer and safer.
That contrast to the old lenders during
the depression who were at the most
vulnerable right at the end. Oh,
I've lost it. Right? Most vulnerable.
Right at the end here,
these lenders are getting less and
less vulnerable as time goes on. Okay?
So that's the advantage
of an amortizing mortgage.
Now it's so happens that the rate of
amortization gets big faster and faster.
So these numbers start at a hundred and
stay pretty close to a hundred and then
they go down pretty fast, which is what
his point is. And that's absolutely right.
And so if you look at the remaining
balance says here in this chart,
it started at 101 to 98 one to 97, 96, 95.
Now 93 92 98 you know,
they're going down faster and faster.
You keep going,
you're going to see that they're going
in all they start leaping down from 73 76
to 73 73 to 70 so you know,
you know,
now they're starting to go from 43 to 38
there really by percentage is going way
down really fast, you know, 21
to 14 to seven to zero. Okay?
So they go down really fast at the
end of the remaining balance. Okay?
But that's just the way the amortizing
fixed, uh, interest mortgage works.
Okay. Now we want to think about how to
value it. All right? So the way we, yeah,
so now let's suppose the,
okay,
so we've got the payment is eight the
coupon that they agreed on in the mortgage
was 7% but that's different from what the
interest rate is in the whole economy,
which is 6% say.
So suppose the interest rate is 6% why
would it be that with a 6% interest rate
today, one year interest rate
today? Why would it be that?
If the interest rate was 6% today,
too complicated the street,
the interest rate were 6% today.
Why?
Why would it be that the mortgage rate
that people would agree to be 6% why is
it that the interest that,
why is it that the mortgage rate people
could agreed to since the 7.3% and this
went down to, you know,
4.9% that's in that tree.
Okay.
Okay, so you tell me why is it that
when the interest rate is 6% today,
so everybody knows on average it's going
to stay around 6% and here I want to
get a loan from a bank to buy a house
and I put up my spectacular houses as
collateral so the banks should feel safe.
It's amortizing and all of that. Um,
they should feel safe as long as they
haven't lent me too much money. Right.
By the way,
if my house is only worth $80 and they
lend me a hundred then the bank's in
trouble.
If the house is worth 100 and they lend
me a hundred the bank might be in some
vulnerable situation if
the house loses value.
So banks would have to be stupid as they
were to make loans of the home value
almost equal to the house value.
But we're going to come back to that.
So suppose the house is worth way more
than a hundred they lend me the, the,
the amount I'm owning the
bank is only going down.
So the house is protecting the bank
completely has no worries of me defaulting
cause it'll just take my house.
Let's take that case.
The interest rate and the economy is
6% and here the bank is charging me 7%
mortgage rate.
That's what we agree on.
And of course when the charges
to be 70% mortgage rate,
I'm going paying $8 every month.
How could that possibly be
fair or to put it another way,
why does the bank have to
charge an mortgage rate
that's way above the starting
interest rate? Why would it have
to do that? Why does it do it?
Why is everyone willing to pay it?
You see what the question is back there?
Yes.
Right.
I've got this really valuable option,
which of course the bank realizes
I can always get out of it.
I can pay the remaining
balance and get out of it.
Now what am I hoping for when I take
my 7% mortgage out from the bank?
What am I hoping for? How am I
going to make money? The homeowner?
Yes.
Right?
So if there's some tremendous inflation,
like there might well be now
some tremendous inflation
in the next five years.
This is a 30 year loan.
If for the next five years,
you know the economy's in so much trouble
and you've got all these homeowners
underwater and we owe so
much money to the Chinese,
we could well see the Fed
engineering a gigantic inflation.
So the interest rate might go up to 10%
I'm continuing to borrow effectively at
7% from the, from the
bank. How can you see that?
Because this remaining balance,
remember the whole way it's structured is
w you know the payments I after a year,
the hundred I borrowed
goes down to be one,
but it's like a 20 year mortgage where
I borrowed be one again at 7% interest
after the third year when I
just after making my payment,
both the 27 years left of the mortgage
are treated explicitly by the law of the
contract as if I borrowed
be $3 at 7% interest.
So in other words,
a mortgage is like a contract where every
year I get to reborrow at 7% but I'm
borrowing a smaller and smaller amount
so I perpetually get to borrow at 7% but
I have the option of canceling the
whole thing by paying off the remaining
balance.
So I'm hoping that the interest rate's
going to go to 12% and I'm going to be
borrowing still at 7% borrowing at 7%
and reinvesting in at 12% I'll make a
killing. I'm praying for
interest rates to go up. Now,
most homeowners think that they're
praying for interest rates to go down,
but they just have it all backwards.
They think of interest rates go down and
get a norm lower mortgage with a lower
interest. They don't realize that the
present value of their future payments is,
are going to go up. So they should be
hoping for the interest rates to go up.
They should be opening for big inflation.
Okay.
And that's when they're
going to make money.
So that and the option
that the homeowner gains,
if interest rates go up and the homeowner
can always get out of the mortgage and
pay it off, if interest rates go down
by paying off the remaining balance,
that's tremendously valuable. Okay,
so how do we compute that value?
We have to do it by backward induction.
Okay, so you can't, you know,
you can intuitively
see there's some value,
but you don't know exactly what it is
until you do it by backward induction.
So here, you know, the payments
are always ate. The payments.
We said we're eight,
we're a 8.05 and 8.05 you know,
and then at the end,
8.05
okay.
So we know that at the end the value,
the, the, the, the present value
of what the bank is going to,
all the present value of how much the
homeowner is going to have to pay.
Let's do it that way. He's going to be
zero. Okay? So we know that at this point,
what's the value that's left as zero
because there are no payments after this
final. That's your 30 the no payments
after that. So what is the value add?
So assume that we've figured out the
value and we're working backwards.
So we're at some node like this one where
we know the interest rate and we want
to figure out what the value is here
just after the coupon payments made.
So what's the value?
Well, the homeowner has,
the option of making remaining balance
from member was being one B two and this
is [inaudible]. So at this
node here, okay, this is zero.
This is times zero.
So we have the zero equals a
hundred at time one the homeowner,
he's made the payment here.
So at time one he could, uh,
just pay B one and B out
of the whole thing. Okay.
Or he could make his payment.
So if he makes his payment,
then he owes the 8.05. So half the, sorry,
he's just made his payment
so he can either get out of
the whole thing by paying
Dijuan or you could wait to
see what happens next period.
So half the time he's going to go up,
so he's going to have to pay 8.05 and
then he's going to have a decision then to
me. But we've already, we're
working by backwards deductions.
We've already solved out for what
the value of his decision is there.
So it's going to be s up.
Okay.
Plus half the time,
uh,
he's going to have to pay 8.05, he's
going to be down here, but we've,
and then he's going to have the remaining,
you know,
he's going to have to decide whether to
pay off the remaining balance or down.
And vs down is that decision.
Okay.
Cause we've already figured out whether
he should prepay or not here. Okay.
So that's it.
It couldn't be simpler at every node
after the coupon payment is made,
the guy has the choice of pain or um,
I mean if prepaying,
you know,
paying off the remaining
balance or waiting till the
next period and then he has
to pay the coupon if he
waits till next period.
And if he doesn't pay the coupon then um,
okay.
Oh, what happened to the interest
rate? Well I forgot it, so thank you.
So I have to put this in brackets
and multiply by one over 1.049.
That's what happened. The
interest rate, I just forgot it.
So either he pays the remaining balance
or he waits and of course he has to
discount it by the interest rate there,
which is of a 1.04,
nine times a half times what happens
over here plus a half times what happens
over here.
That's it.
And that's what I've
written down in the nodes.
So here are the interest rate nodes
and here are the present value.
So here's the non callable mortgage.
Okay, so the non callable mortgage,
if the at the homeowner, we're so
stupid that he never prepaid and he's,
and the interest rate is 7% the mortgage
interest rate is 7% and the interest
rate starts at 6%. That's obviously
great for the bank. The Guy Stupid,
they always going to pay never prepaids
the bank makes $109 but if the guy is
much smarter than that,
if the guys much smarter than that,
um,
sorry,
that's the guy, he's much smarter
than that and he's going to call.
And now lo and behold, the
valley's only 95.55. Okay?
The option is so valuable that even
though the interest rate is 7% is 6% the
mortgage rate is 7% the bankers chart
incredibly overcharging him and the,
uh, you know, and, and, and
the guy will never default.
Still the bank is getting a terrible
deal because the option is so valuable to
the, to the, uh, to the guy.
Okay. So what is the bank going to
do in that case? What would a bank do
if you were the banker?
What would you do? The interest rate is
6% you can't control the interest rates.
That's the whole economy.
Everybody's patience and impatience and
all the Fisher stuff is determining all
these interest rates. What would you
do for your, uh, what would you do?
You, you wouldn't charge
7% is your mortgage rate.
You'd have to charge a higher mortgage
rate. Maybe you charge 8% okay.
And so we could just change the whole
thing to 8% and we do it and you'll see
that the guy will do better.
So the mortgage rate,
let's put it as 0.075 okay.
Instead of 0.07 so now the annual
payments gone up and everything's going to
change. And so the interest
rate process is the same.
If the guy never prepaids it's now
worth 114 and if the guy does prepay
optimally,
well you still haven't gotten it high
enough of have to make it 8% maybe. Okay.
So the interest rate looks like
it'll have to get to a lot above
6% maybe we'll have to go to
8% maybe 8% isn't enough. Well,
on average,
let's just write 0.08 and now
we can see how that worked out.
Interest rate processes the same.
Look at this and the guy never prepays
it's worth 120 if he does free pay,
it's still not enough. So it's
going to have to be 9% or something.
Now typically if the interest rate is
6% the mortgage rate will be something
like seven and a half percent not
the 9% or 10% I'd have to get up to.
So why do you think that is?
Yes,
exactly.
You have to count on the dumb p.
So that's an important fact of life.
You not only have to count on them,
you have to count them.
So you have to figure out what
fraction of the population is this.
It's going to only pay you 98 in the end.
And what fraction of
the population is this?
They're going to pay you 120 in the end.
Okay.
And if you knew which of
the guys with 120 guys,
what fraction with 120 guys and
what fraction of their 98 guys,
you'd know what the, the, uh,
the thing was worth. Okay.
And it's going to be okay,
so, all right, so, um,
how far am I going? All right. So
if you're a mortgage hedge fund,
my company is a mortgage hedge fund.
That's where we started out with.
We quickly did these calculations
and now, um, all right,
so if you look at the data, you're
going to find, oh, by the way,
Sunday I'm having remember this extra
class Sunday night to tell you a little
bit about the real world.
So I'm going to save the stories of
all the data and stuff until then.
But basically we look at how people
have behaved in the past, you know,
so we're doing this tree and we're
figuring out, you know, from this tree,
you can figure out when the people
should have prepaid or not. Okay.
Actually the next tree, if you have
a dollar's worth of principle, okay.
If you assume that the original principal
was a dollar instead of a hundred and
you always figured out at every node,
what would a dollar's worth of principle
be there. Okay, you can, you can,
you can find out in an easy
way when people should prepay.
So here you can see where all the ones
are is when they should have prepaid.
So I don't have time now to explain that.
But anyway,
just a slight modification of the tree
shows you one, they should prepay.
So you can look at when people should
prepay and he can look in the data at how
many of the people do prepay. So
you can go house by house, you know,
it's public information. Are these people
prepaying or aren't they prepaying?
How smart are they?
And you can deduce from having watched
them in the past miss opportunity after
opportunity to prepay.
You know that these guys now,
it's not a matter of being stupid.
In fact,
the smartest people might
be the ones not prepaying,
they're not paying attention or maybe
it's a real hassle for them to prepay.
So we're going to come to the
reasons why they won't prepay.
So you have to calibrate how many people
are behaving optimally and how many
people aren't.
And then you can judge how high you
have to set the interest rate to make a
reasonable profit. And I'm going
to talk more about that next time.